welcome back okay so we've been talking
about data-driven regression to obtain
models for for model predictive control
so we're doing system identification
based on data we're finding best fit
models that fit the data using
regression and we're going to use that
for control we talked about DMD with
control Koopman with control now I want
to tell you about the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics
with control so this is essentially a
framework to get fully nonlinear models
X dot equals f of X comma you fully
nonlinear models purely from data that
you can then use in this model
predictive control optimization okay so
I'm just going to give you a very very
quick overview of the original Sindhi
method the basic idea here is if I have
some measurement data my system let's
say this is the lorentz system that
should not be a box and that should be I
think a row that should be a row anyway
if I have some measurement data of some
nonlinear dynamical system what I can do
is I can form this data into these tall
columns that evolve in time so my three
state variables x y and z and time and x
dot y dot and z dot and what Cyndi does
is it essentially builds this nonlinear
library theta of X of all of the
candidate functions that could be in
these right hand side dynamics so these
can be evaluated with data and then it
uses sparse regression to find the
fewest columns in this library that
gives you X dot s-- the fewest columns
that give you y dot and the fewest
columns that give you Z dot using sparse
regression and then what you end up
recovering is a dynamical system that
agrees with your original system and it
identifies the correct nonlinear
structure ok so this is pretty cool
method of nonlinear system
identification purely from data it's
formulated as a linear regression
problem so we essentially build all of
the non-linearity into this theta matrix
and then we do sparsity regularized
linear regression to find the fewest
columns that agree with x dot y dot and
z
okay so this is really just a big ax
equals B solve once we built this
library now a couple things of interest
you can definitely do this in discrete
time too this doesn't have to be X dot y
dot Z dot this could be x y&z at time
step k plus 1 as some non linear
function of those variables at time step
k so you can do this in discrete time
now what I'm going to tell you about is
how you can use this cyndy algorithm
this sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics to not only identify unforced
dynamical systems but now to identify
systems with actuation and control so if
you want to know more about this I'll
point you to a video in the comments
where you can learn all about Cindy but
now we're going to apply this to Cindy
with control ok so this is a modified
version of Cindy where now instead of
just building a library of functions of
X like X x squared X cubed and so on now
what we're going to do is allow our
library to include cross terms that
include the actuation u so my library
includes X u x squared X u and so on and
so forth this library is only limited by
by your imagination so this can this
doesn't have to include polynomials that
can have cosines and sines tangents
Bessel functions whatever you want but
the idea with Cindi with control is
we're going to apply that same sparse
regression procedure to find the best
fit X dot the fewest columns of this
matrix that agree with the time
derivative of my measurement vector X ok
and so essentially I build this library
from data I'm gonna illustrate this on a
pretty simple system so this is the
classic predator-prey lotka-volterra
where you essentially get these
oscillations and predator and prey
populations these kind of phase lag
oscillations so you know bunnies grow
and then wolves grow to catch up the
Wolves eat all the bunnies so their
population collapses then the Wolves
have no food so they die off then the
bunnies grow and so on and so forth so
this evolves in time ok so what we're
essentially doing original sin D you
could identify the lock
tarah dynamics with no problem just from
this data Cindy could identify those
nonlinear dynamics but now let's say
that I have some actuation and control
that I'm actively modifying the system
with some feedback control so for the
example in the case of population
dynamics
maybe I'm actively going and hunting
wolves and this actually happened back
in the I think this was the Appalachia
trapping records they would there were
records of links and hair so you had a
predator and a prey but they were
actively trapping these animals for
their pelts and so there was this active
feedback control modifying the dynamics
of the system okay so that's kind of the
the test case here is let's say we
actually can measure some actuation
you--that's modifying these dynamics and
see if we can learn those the nonlinear
dynamics and the effective actuation in
this case I just write down the
equations with some control input I
simulate them to generate my data and
the idea here is from time zero to a
hundred I have one control strategy
maybe here I'm you know aggressively
trapping wolves okay so that's one one
control strategy and then at time step
one hundred my control strategy changes
so my u that input vector U changes at
time step one hundred okay so kind of
zero to 100 is my training data 100 to
200 is my validation data and what you
can essentially see is if I do naive
Cindy if I do regular Cindy but I don't
take into account the fact that I'm
actively controlling my system then I
can agree quite well in my training
period but then when I switch my control
input my Cindy model starts to diverge
because it fundamentally doesn't capture
the fact that there's this control
variable U that's forcing my system
whereas my Cindy with control model
knows that there's this u that's
affecting my system and as long as I
measure what that U is I can accurately
trace different control strategies in
the future okay so the blue
agrees well with my validation okay so
that's kind of the the high level view
of Cindy with control is basically you
build this this augmented library that
has not just your state dynamics but
also takes into account the actuation so
that when you measure your dynamics and
train the model it disambiguates the
internal nonlinear dynamics from the
effective actuation and control so that
if I change my control strategy at some
point my cindy with control model is
able to compensate whereas in a naive
cindy model would fail okay and here's a
nice diagram that Erica Kaiser made in
this archive paper for the lorentz
system so this is basically that big
cindy cindy picture but now with control
so here we have our Lorentz dynamics
with some actuation you in the first
state X so now I have my data collection
XY and Z and U and now I do this sparse
regression in this augmented library
that includes nonlinear functions of my
states and control and what you find is
you can simultaneously identify the
unforced dynamics and the effective
actuation
okay so Cindy with control is powerful
data-driven regression technique that
allows you to identify input-output
models that are nonlinear okay so some
non linear dynamical system and the
possibly non linear effective actuation
okay so what we can then do is take
those cindy with control models and wrap
a model predictive control or around it
and see if we can stabilize or modify
the behavior of a strongly nonlinear
system okay that's all coming up thank
you